another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the foundation no  interacting with scp-5555-j  under any circumstances scp-5555-j  is capable of reducing any living  organism to a miniature or chibi if  you'd prefer version of itself dr bright  may claim he is trying to make teacup  pigs to hand out at the office as an  incentive but do not fall for it the  last time dr bright was exposed to  scp-5555-j  the miniature version it produced of him  was a miniature orangutan he was brought  into custody and proceeded to behave  quite poorly with some of his own  bathroom material and completely destroy  the attending researcher's clothing  before escaping to wreck even more havoc  dr bright knows what minnie him did and  he has lost his  55-55-j privileges for good